[Music]
foreign
how's he doing I know he's doing so much
better because
um I'm actually about to do something
special for him uh and doing him a favor
he's awake you know they say he's alert
so we love it all right that's great
that is good that's family that's family
right there another topic that
everybody's talking about you just did a
movie with um Alec box with Alec Baldwin
I've been you know supporting him he's
one of the greats but then obviously the
unfortunate and tragic situation that uh
he was in in the middle of that man like
when when things like that happen all
you can do is pray for your friends and
your colleagues and the prayers were
answered yeah but how hard is that for
someone to try and focus and work while
they're dealing with something and that
was the Brilliance of it and then once
you see our film which is called uh
Hollywood Heist you'll see that it's the
inner workings of Hollywood so he's
almost playing a very similar like
character and the the film has this like
Big Lebowski Pulp Fiction type of vibe I
want you on my team but we got an
exclusive behind the scenes look at the
upcoming movie and Nick's got big plans
coming up twins Moroccan and Monroe are
turning 12 on Sunday you remember you
came to uh Six Flags yes it's a very
beginning yeah where me and Mariah we
shut it down I'm doing that for that
birthday again this year Nick's keeping
it in the family for his newest project
the daily Cannon Morning Show on AMP
Abby De la Rosa who is mom two three of
Nick's 12 kids is one of his co-hosts
we're not just covering pop culture we
creating pop culture moments there's
gonna be interviews you'll get to see
our bond you'll get to see you know why
so much love there and I mean the kids
would be upstairs while we're downstairs
doing the show will we ever see the kids
will the kids ever see mommy and daddy
working no I think exactly right
especially I mean like because the twins
are running around all over the place
they'll definitely pop in
[Music]
thank you